is he speaking
do you understand him in a way
grogo and i can feel each other's
thoughts
that's like a uh dragon ball z muppets
mashup
this will be grogan that's his name
kamehameha whoa welcome back to new rock
stars this is our reaction to the
mandalorian season 2 episode 5 chapter
13
the jedi this episode brings in
ahsoka freakin tato to explain the
child's backstory
and name which is apparently
confirmed to be grogu you know and
they did all this just to give the poor
child the anakin skywalker treatment i
can't trade him he's too old he's too
scared he's too
fat and he's too loving now get
get out of here poor kid
well uh this is wikileaks it is our
mandalorian after show i'm eric voss uh
on a brief furlough from the blue
dungeon for thanksgiving i'm here with
tommy uh yeah hey buddy
i'm starting to think that jedi's just
don't like teaching
like they're like they're like they're
like the college professors that are
forced to come out of their field of
choice
and go home and teach a college class
they're like i don't want to do this i
want to be making film
i'm about cinema i don't want to teach
young frankenstein to another class of
18 year old
i was one phone call away from working
with one j
ajay abrams before i had to take this
gig that's correct i'm friends with
marty heard of him scorsese
no she everyone's friends with him they
just don't know it yet
that's he's very active on parlor just
kidding i think he's a democrat
anyway you've learned uh so much this
episode
uh tying in everything that we want to
be tie in from
star wars rebels including grand admiral
thrawn which also probably means ezra
bridger guys
uh now in terms of just grogu in his
whole timeline
you may have already seen already rushed
out a video of explaining the
significance
i was able to go into the dungeon real
quick to get that done yeah
i was dazzled by that ted talk nerd
stuff um now tomorrow will be my uh
separate in-depth easter egg breakdown
of all the stuff that you missed and
this is wikileaks we're going to go into
a lot of it here um but before
tommy recaps the episode uh not only do
i have this reminder that you can still
purchase a limited edition this is away
shirt
exclusive from new rockstars official
merch store new rockstarsmerch.com
we also ordered like 50 more of the red
and white varieties so even though
they've been sold out for most of the
run you can probably snag a colored
variant issue if you act quickly
another reason you should hack quickly
is because today
is the first day of our black friday ten
percent off sale
that is ten percent off everything
store-wide starting today
through midnight on cyber monday
november 30th uh
to celebrate epic hero shops first black
friday they are dropping a bunch of
new designs available for order uh
my favorite obviously is the new easter
egg line
these designs are for the die-hard fans
who will get every tiny reference
basically
they should come work for us if they
find them all in this this one
celebrates the upcoming release of
wandavision and it is
chock full of easter eggs from the
movies show in comics
also boom you're looking for this shirt
well
you found it yes we had to do it we made
a boom are you looking for this shirt
uh this is phillip in it uh actually
phillip um
last night he that madman knocked out
a brand new shirt to celebrate the
reveal of the child's real name
uh this has got to be the first shirt
out there that has a little baby grow
goo by his real name
in his adorable little mug shot because
he's a little monster uh so yeah go snag
all of those shirts they will make great
holiday presents as long as you order
them as soon as possible
and a special reward for those who
didn't jump ahead in the video
skipping this ad you we know who you are
for listening through this you can get
an extra five
percent off an extra five percent off
that's in addition to the already
applied ten percent
discount for everyone you just gotta
enter the code new
rockstars black at checkout so that's
new rockstarsmerch.com
10 off for everyone and an extra five
percent uh for you
with the code new rockstars black and as
always when you buy the mando shirt for
a few bucks more you can also write in a
custom shout out a hot tag whatever and
it'll appear beneath us in these
wikileaks episode you can see a couple
below stephen bortorello said
uncle tommy excluded from people's
sexiest man list
cancelled thank you steven i also was
hurt by that sub but
they come out with one every year so
let's start the campaign for 2021
guys let's do this uh also
it looks like levi uh sans sane said
alderaan more like alder gone
i'll let myself out yeah
levi we would be friends yeah well what
happened this episode tommy so much
see if you can break it down for us
let's talk about
the alarm bells ringing in the city of
caledon
a beautiful almost like a liberty bell
type chime
uh and similarly cracked by the end of
the episode i do believe the liberty
bell in philadelphia was cracked by
lightsaber
it's a conspiracy theory that i run on
my own personal page
uh tommy points uh anyway so we're onto
the planet corvus
uh the city guards are fighting off a
former jedi we get her immediately
ahsoka tano
first few opening moments of the episode
which i love i love a good band-aid rib
for like a casting mystery show we
already knew she was
exactly there's no surprise that this
character was showing up we knew from
the
the the trailer earlier that she was
coming so like do it right away
using her uh amazing skills the twin
lightsabers we see her dispatch the
guards and then she gets to the city
gate where she's confronted by
magistrate
morgan ellsbeth and her lieutenant lang
shout out to michael bean
terminator one in the house can we say
morgan ellsbeth
is definitely a girl who your little
sister spent the night at
one point yes where is she's at morgan
hillsborough's house
um morgan l smith is bullying on the
[ __ ] and that girl had to call
her parents to come pick her up
that's right morgan elsma's parents are
getting a divorce but her dad just
bought her a horse
uh anyway so katana gives the magistrate
one day to surrender and give her the
location of her
mysterious master which will be revealed
uh meanwhile the mandalorian and the
child
fly and land outside the city that
existed just a disgusting part of porvus
a real syracuse new york energy if you
ask me
whoa shots that's gonna i
i'm just antagonizing the snowbelt right
now so then he reaches the city gate
where he introduces himself as a bounty
hunter and is taken directly to the
magistrate on the way to the
magistrate's quarters he notices that
some of the citizens have been
hung up and are being tortured with
electrical shocks that was uh
a terrifying uh way to be tortured just
like an electric prison
cell that's literally the size of a
basketball hoop around you so
the magistrate makes a straightforward
offer kill the jedi uh that's troubling
her and then uh she'll give her
mando a best car steal staff that's in
her her possession we know how
mandalorians are with bhaskar they can't
resist them it's
it's like gollum to the ring uh he's
given the last known coordinates of
sokatano and he goes on his way so he's
searching for ahsoka
in this awful wasteland uh similar to
the carrier dome in syracuse
new york and she surprises him but he's
able to fend her off uh
he's able to fend off the attacks
because uh this is the first instance we
see of the best car really repelling the
lightsabers
yeah that's sturdy stuff kind of
fascinating and kind of goes back to the
mythology and the lore of the you know
mandalorians fighting the jedi maybe
that was why they were able to actually
it was a it was a fight rather than just
a massacre uh so anyway
before things get out of hand he tells
her that he's not really going out there
to kill her of course but that bo kitan
has sent him
which manages to immediately cool uh
ahsoka down she's not in attack mode
anymore ahsoka then sees the child
and is immediately drawn to it which is
cool the two of them are interacting
ahsoka doesn't say a single word
but is able to ascertain a lot of
information about the child here
nando is pacing because there's a new
parent in town and there's a
father-son jealousy action uh but then
that's when we get the great reveal
of uh baby yoda who i will still refer
to as baby oda forever uh
has a name and it is grogu uh she
mentions that she's only ever seen one
other being
like him master yoda sorry yaddle i
guess you're uh
you're out she's never seen yodel
she's out most of us have never seen
yato so yeah uh ahsoka then reveals that
grogu was raised at the jedi temple and
has been trained by many masters so like
that kind of that isn't for me a
question because i was kind of wondering
like why was this kid so was he just
naturally gifted at using the force was
he so powerful but no evidently he's
received some type of training
he's taken some workshops he's graduated
from the ucb curriculum
he knows how to move stuff with him he's
having an advanced study class doing
clowning
he's doing clown work this is such an
inside baseball joke that
no one will find your phone oh yeah if
they know what they are
so so that's true so ahsoka can kind of
sense that
that the child has this connection with
mando and that's why she refuses to
train him
because she's afraid that grogu will
will go down a darker path due to due to
the fear that he would have over
protecting nando and
the love like it's just too emotional we
know how jedis are about emotions
they're like irish catholics
you got to shove them all down until you
get uh inoperable cancer
so uh mandalorian proposes a deal
that uh he'll help her dispatch with the
magistrate if she will in turn
train the child aka baby yoda aka kuroku
and she accepts
ahsoka mentions that the magistrate is
uh not an opponent to be taken lightly
as she has helped the empire build
the entire imperial starfleet and it
seems like she's still at work because
that town
uh the the city looks like it's been
pretty stripped bare there's not a lot
of greenery
ironically only in her in the
magistrate's little temple area does
there seem to be anything growing so
ahsoka and mando storm the city they
take out the lights that chop the bell
in half which is pretty awesome my
personal favorite of mine uh and then
they just go to town
literally going to town and dispatching
of all the guards the magistrates
assistants and finally ahsoka ends up
one-on-one with the magistrate
she uh fights her with the best car
staff but she finally knocks the staff
out of the hands and says
very meaningful uh sentence that kind of
leaves the door open for a lot of
possibilities of this
in the upcoming episodes of middleware
which is now tell me
where is your master where is grand
admiral thrawn
so pretty crazy mando dispatches of uh
michael bean which was very depressing
for me although i didn't figure he was
long for the world
i liked that he was a rascal i love i
love like a good old piece
he's like this fight isn't worth it yeah
psych but he smiles
he's such a terrible he was such a
terrible poker face like he was like
he's like i give up and then he's dead
so uh mando uh has left the child on the
ship and then he goes to get the child
to get his half of the bargain with
ahsoka which is she has to train
the child now uh so he goes and has kind
of a
sad goodbye but then ahsoka still
refuses to train him so
they're still going to be together and
she says the mandalorians become like a
father to grogu and that he should take
the child to tython
where there are where there are runes of
an old jedi temple she believes grogu
can there decide his own fate his own
course by tapping into the force of the
temple
amanda needs to set grogu down on the
stone
and then he can call out to another jedi
uh luke skywalker maybe
uh i'm sure we'll theorize on that later
so otherwise
it's up to the mandalorian mandalorian
dead gets the child and starts
uh on the journey to tyson so that's it
pretty crazy episode a lot of a lot of
questions
questions there was yeah i mean this
like was nuts they revealed so much just
in this time
and by saying admiral thrawn is the the
object of her search that probably means
ezra bridger is tied into that or
was i the thought on that later uh but
poor man
oh this is really just like um i was
told by the county clerk that i have to
come back to the dmv
to get my tags re-registered now you're
telling me i have to go to
santa clarita do you what yeah it's
it's really just gonna be one place to
another but that's what makes it fun
because you get to tie in books
absolutely
and maybe now luke that that ah like the
action of this episode looked incredible
i loved it reminded me of that uh
awesome moment in phantom menace
how there's like the gas fog in the room
and just by the
ignition of the lightsabers and the
droids don't know where they are
just by the lightsaber it identifies the
jedi and by making those the twin white
sabers
already fans of the animated series know
that this is going to tie into rebels
so it's just awesome that it's that and
out of some random blue one that she
made later like
obviously it's dave filoni he makes both
so but i just love the title yes
i do too no notes on this episode for me
very much
maybe not maybe not enough jeans guy uh
peering in from around the corner but
you know he was there he was there if
you look real close he's the slender man
somewhere in those streets
he's a force ghost now because he was
immediately fired from the
from the crew uh let's dive into some of
the deeper meaning of this tommy
tommy you started to touch on it a
little bit uh because in ahsoka's denial
the train grogu she essentially used the
same justification that master yoda may
swindo obi-wan
several others used with the young
anakin skywalker in the prequels they
initially said
that uh personal connections make you
weak
in the jedi order as tommy called it
irish catholic syndrome
um now uh ahsoka even
echoes yoda's words she says i sense
much fear in you
that was essentially the spirit of yoda
speaking through her
uh and you can see that heartbreak
rosario dawson did such a good job
when uh she said i've seen what such
feelings can do to a fully trained jedi
knight
to the best of us all that was referring
to her old friend anakin skywalker
whom she believes allowed his fiery
passions
to blind him to the corruption that was
taking hold of him and she doesn't want
history to repeat itself with grogu
because she saw it basically destroyed
the catholic lives
whether permanently or just altered of
many of her friends and people she cared
about so
yeah the states are much harder yeah
um now ahsoka observes that mando is
like a father to him that they love each
other which is so nice for an outside
observer to
to recognize what we've been seeing and
um she fears that that love
is the same pure love that anakin felt
for his mother and for padme and that
that love was too powerful to let
any zen wisdom that the jedi could teach
take hold
but i would say tommy that really the
fear that she sensed
was her own fear it was not the fear of
the child
because i was surprised to hear ahsoka
echo one of the most dogmatic maxims of
the jedi order
because she if you remember in clone
wars dramatically
parted ways with the jedi order she
knows that that is a flawed institution
still i guess as one of the few jedi
that still exist in this universe she is
the eponymous
jedi of the episode title felony kind of
endows her with that certain point of
view
uh but we should not forget that point
of view is an
f'd up culti one uh luke's victory
in return of the jedi proves wrong the
conventional wisdom of you know what
people thought the tragedy of vader was
returning the jedi proved to us that
love is the ultimate
redeemer and the love between mando and
grogu
is the same thing it makes them strong
grogu's first
use of the force on the show was sadie
mando from the mudhorn that was an act
of love and it is that moment
that defines mando's sigil on his armor
and further underlining i think
interestingly the failure of the jedi
dogma the stark uh some would say
syracuse-esque landscape imagery of this
episode wait for the comments on this
when uh bogatan promised us this forest
planet i was imagining a
you know uh lord of the ringsy but not
mordor lord of the rings you know
uh lush green forest uh instead
a row of dead burnt trees
like post-volcano eruption uh but not to
the point where it's like oh hope might
spring
in this fertile ash no no it's just died
uh
now trees are sacred to jedi mythology
for example there's the great force tree
on on notch too
you know that's an important thing to
them an important image
um an important symbol uh but in the
last jedi
importantly importantly the force ghost
of yoda
allowed that tree to be burnt down and
that was a
signal to luke skywalker that the jedi
order is dead we need to let
those past rules die and i think that's
what the episode was kind of hinted at
despite
ahsoka's stubbornness around her
everywhere she looks
is an example of how the jedi order
failed in their strict strict documents
so uh the same must be learned by
this yodeling grogu and i think he
already knows it
is that you must always choose love and
connection with others
over all else and in that can be your
greatest strength
i think it's amazing we you know
basically grogu is non-verbal right like
we're only able
we're basically inferring and
ascertaining things
about a practical puppet that is like
hand movements eye movements and ear
movements
and it's amazing how much we kind of can
can conclude or at least
hypothesize about this little being
already based on the information we're
given from characters and just by his
own actions
so it's it's really kind of a remarkable
achievement of like
you know uh affects engineering yeah and
i think
honestly that's the secret to his
success i think the fact that he doesn't
have a voice that can either be like
nails on a chalkboard
or like have a wave of popularity then
people start to turn
on it just leaving it uh it's almost
like the chaplin effect like
uh that's what we lost when we lost
silent films is like just by a
visual like you convey so much with no
words or dialogue that sometimes a show
is better without it some of my favorite
episodes of all tv shows are ones where
there's
hardly any dialogue uh and that's i mean
the the final
five or six minutes sequence of the
clone wars series
zero dialogue and it was honestly i
think the best five minutes of the
series
uh and i they think those are those go
together um
now we're gonna dive into there's a lot
of uh theories we gotta we gotta talk
about
real quick i wanna thank some people who
helped us make this episode starting
with our friends at bespoke post this
fall
bespoke post has a brand new seasonal
box of awesome collections for guys
guaranteed to upgrade your life i
recently got a box with a german steel
knife and a carving fork i
felt like dwight schrute as i was
carving up my thanksgiving turkey
it was amazing they got a gear to
upgrade your craft beers and cozy
threats for cold weather bespoke post
only sends guys the best
stuff every month so whatever you're
into box of awesome has you covered
style and grooming goods bar wear
outdoor gear box of awesomeness
collections for every part of your life
they have a snazzy sweater box and
another box that's a bunch of
interesting hot sauces
so you can feel like you're on episode
hot ones because they're never going to
invite you on that because you're not
famous come on
to get started take a quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month across different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month uh or cancel anytime
each box only costs 45 bucks but has
over
70 dollars worth of gear inside get
20 off your first monthly box when you
sign up at box of awesome.com and enter
the code
mandalorian at checkout that's
boxyboston.com code mandalorian for 20
off your first box we also want to thank
our good friends that manscaped
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
men actually shaved their balls with the
same razor as their face
well not anymore thanks to our sponsors
that manscaped the best in men's below
the way screw me and manscaped is here
to stop you from looking like a
chewbacca down there
like a chewbacca there's only one uh for
all we know mando
is uh never nude but i imagine that a
cool customer like denjarin would want
to keep nice and clean downstairs so the
best car doesn't change it's true
um manscape is forever changing the
grooming game with their perfect package
3.0
inside the perfect package you will find
their electric trimmer the lawnmower 3.0
that waterproof and skin safe trimmer
will reduce mix and it
is the droid you're looking for it also
includes the crop preserver anti-chafing
ball deodorant moisturizer the crop
reviver ball toner spray
and the anti-chafing performance boxer
briefs in a very sharp
black color that is just down right
imperial
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com mandalorian that is 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
mandalorian may the force be with you
or balls and uh finally expressvpn thank
you for also sponsoring this episode we
all know a vpn protects your privacy and
security online you might not know that
you can use a vpn to
unlock movies and shows that are only
available in other countries
you can use expressvpn to binge doctor
who
on uk netflix or tons of anime on
netflix japan
it's simple you just fire up the
expressvpn app you change your location
to the country that you want
you refresh netflix and boom you're done
that's it uh expressvpn hides your ip
address so it lets you control where you
want the sites to think you're located
and you can choose
from almost 100 different countries
that's a lot of netflix libraries
and it's not just netflix expressvpn
works on any streaming service hulu bbc
iplayer youtube you name it there are
hundreds of vpns out there
but i use expressvpn to watch shows
because it is ridiculously fast
there is never any buffering no lag you
can stream it on hd
no problem exercising is also compatible
with your phones your smart tvs all your
other devices
you can watch what you want or go on the
big screen wherever you
are and if you visit my special link
right now at expressvpn.com you can get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free
support the show watch what you want and
protect yourself at expressvpn.com
mandalorian okay tommy here we go uh
time
to dive into the big questions of this
episode
so what do we need to talk about well
eric who do you think took grogu from
the jedi temple and where has he been
since okay i i started to go into this
in the other video
really if you think about who the jedi
were who were at the tip of the time of
order 66 yoda and obi-wan got there the
very end after most of them were killed
but we know from jedi fallen order that
uh jedi were elsewhere all over the
place a lot of jedi
might have been able to get away but the
presumption from
the original trilogy is that uh jedi are
basically a myth they're like um
a dying breed that many people think
never existed that's how
few there are left so i think we're
either looking at obi-wan
and there was just like a cut scene from
revenge of the sith where he discovered
this thing and brought it back with him
and that's something we could explore in
the
kenobi series um it would be too
early obviously luke skywalker was not
or he would have been a baby
so i don't think he could rescue another
baby um uh i think
uh you could lump in yoda there um
i have had theories in the other video
that it could have been yattle uh one
who was specifically mentioned in jedi
fallen order as
hopefully still being alive um some
people are saying it could be jocasta
new the librarian the one who says if
it's not on the map
it doesn't make sense you know i would
imagine her
uh having you know a weird corner of a
rare book section
that's where she keeps sitting and she's
like well i have to help this one
and that that would be she just she's
old you know
and she didn't make it but the baby did
that's my theory um
and then uh in terms of where he's been
since i don't think the new republic
ever knew about his existence i don't
think luke
knows yet i feel like i feel like that
would have been
an immediate if there was another yoda
like being in the universe luke would
have
dropped everything to get him i think
what had happened is whatever jedi
uh freed him whether it was jocasta new
or someone who has a bit more fighting
skill
um lost to or got hijacked or pirated by
this meek doe cartel uh those were the
ones who had him at the beginning that's
one who tried to recover
the child in chapter 10 of this season
and they have been they didn't even know
what they had
uh but they had it for years and years
and years and then someone's like hey i
think it's important
we can cut a deal and that's maybe they
kind of deal with the client
um and he's been sending bounty hunters
ever since well that that's grogu
where has ahsoka tano been since we last
saw her why is she looking for grand
admiral thrawn
okay well she's looking for grand
admiral thrawn because she's trying to
find ezra like so she left uh when we
last saw her
um she was leaving with sabine wren
in the final scene of star wars rebels
uh uh ezra bridger and thrawn were on
this like hyperspace
chase and then hyperspace blasted the
two of them to some unknown place that's
the last we saw them
so the fact that she's looking for ezra
bridger uh thrawn is the key to that
um but here's my uh curiosity about this
i think they want thrawn to be uh an
interesting
big character in the show why not like
he has been
thrawn is amazing he is the reason we
have such a beloved um
expanded universe he was introduced in
this 1991
heir to the empire expanded universe
novel and
all three of those books he's
essentially this imperial navy
genius and some people compared to like
spock uh but he's a star wars character
he's better
uh he uh was you know initially brought
on as a guy charged to try to keep the
empire together after
um the battle of endor um but he was
so popular that he was brought into
rebels season three
and he butt heads this was taking place
before those books uh
and are officially canon um and he put
heads with the crew the ghost
until like he and ezra bridge um so yeah
she's trying to
find ezra this could also mean that ezra
and sabine are gonna be joining the show
in live-action form however
um i think she was viciously angry when
she was asking where grand admiral
throneheart
is and sabine was not with her so i'm
thinking
maybe in the years since she already
found them
uh and ezra might not have made it
sabine might not have
made it but thrawn could have gotten
away and now ahsoka is looking for
revenge yeah well that revenge is
certainly important to the star wars uh
universe that is a yeah and she doesn't
despite being so like i can't train him
he's too emotional she was not really
exercising
the you know uh gold standard principles
of the jedi order
she was uh taking lethal force yeah
as much as she could justified of course
but
um yeah i don't know if she's
she's being motivated by any kind of
like sense of uh
peace keeping yeah at all she is uh
she seems in attack mode absolutely all
right so let's talk about this planet
typhon
yeah tython uh how how is it important
to the star wars universe and what jedi
do you think grogu is going to connect
with when he yeah
that's going to be the big question
heading up which is surprising i don't
know if we'll see ahsoka again this
season i hope i hope we see her collide
sabers with uh with uh mock idiom but so
tython is uh
this another one of these things that
started from the legends continuity it
first appeared in um
the 2007 novel dark bane rule of two it
was uh considered the
home homeworld of the jedi order that
was a predecessor to the jedi order
but um in the new established canon
typhon came up uh on a map that was in a
force awakens role-playing game
in 2016 and then later in the 2019 comic
dr aphra 40. um so tython contains
as asuka mentioned these ruins of an
ancient jedi temple
um and some debate it may be the jedi
order's very first jedi temple it's kind
of up there with like
jedha and achtu and even the temple on
coruscant
as like these historical sites of
significance in the jedi religion
um now as you mentioned not
many active jedi right now luke
skywalker's one we know about uh but
also
we know from the rise of skywalker that
uh leia
was a jedi that he trained her enough so
that she could weirdly space fly
and yeah but uh so there's a few jedi
they're probably the oldest jedi that we
know about unless unless unless
this show is going to reveal that some
other jedi
uh escaped from the jedi temple
uh or were just off world we know we
know from like other
stories that certain jedi were off world
but they were hunted down they were
purged
so uh there's still not many options so
it's either gonna be a completely new
character that we don't know about
uh or it's going to be luke skywalker
all right so what happened to morgan
elizabeth and what is her connection to
thrawn
well uh her parents are allowing her no
more sleepovers until she learns to stop
bullying and get along with the less
popular girls
um so yeah they mentioned how
morgan ellsbeth helped uh plunder and
destroy these worlds to help the empire
build their
uh imperial star fleet um sure i don't
think she's doing that now it's
interesting that she considers thrawn
her master
and her um um bo staff
just beau it's you know what me to say
post staff her her combat skills are
pretty great
um and it's interesting that they pulled
that detail because thrawn was a weapons
officer before he rose up to be
a grand admiral um so he
had these great hand-to-hand melee
skills and it seems like that's one of
the things that
he was able to pass on to her i hope
that thrawn
is no longer trying to serve the cause
of the empire that's what moth
canadian's doing i hope thrawn is trying
to build his own fleet his own empire
he's just like a crazy genius space
pirate now
and he he has this uh you know
apprentice that he's kind of training
in his own new religion his own new way
and let's build this outward let's stop
making this everything's empire or
everything's
resistant slash rebellion let's let's
have like third forces in here that are
also because that's how the real world
works you don't have like light and dark
you have oh also we have this
ally that will switch sides and in
different generations
and yeah and not to make it uh not to
tie it into another
uh fantasy uh story but that's what when
game of thrones was really singing was
when there were
multiple powerful forces
that could align and betray each other
and swing the odds in favor of an
underdog in
an instant and then betray them for
their own interests so rather than
having
gideon and thrawn on the same side i
think having them be
threats to each other yeah as well as
the our our heroes
is way more interesting yeah that's why
i think introducing thrawn this way
is the most exciting to me this isn't
just another imperial threat this is
another threat to both sides
that could be a huge political aligning
game changer on this show
even bigger than just knowing that the
kid's name is grogu right which
speaking of grogu we just got to talk
about what is his fixation with the orb
knob
on the control lever i mean there is
like is that there's the weird like orb
imagery with the jedis like the training
lightsaber training thing was kind of a
floating orb wasn't it that obi-wan made
luke train on yeah maybe they're just
drawn to like maybe it's something about
the like
precision of a sphere or perfection of a
sphere or something like that right
i don't know i mean i'm reaching maybe
he's just a kid who likes
like it reminds him of a toy it's just a
ball like everyone's saying he's just
who wants his boss so i'm reading into
it even though i clicked on video to
subscribe to a channel that actually had
all these things i hate it
yeah even though i'd live for your
analysis yeah
uh no i think they're the fact that they
keep revisiting
this particular thing is interesting it
is the same shape as the frog eggs i
know
i don't want to read too much of those
either but i don't know maybe
maybe that kid was taking the death star
at some point right oh yeah
he he's around canonically when it
existed or there during the second death
star
and he just like saw its creation or was
taken to it in some like um
uh traumatic moment and he's just like
wants to hold it because it's a ball i
don't know
what if what if baby oda is just like
the forest gump of jedi's like he's just
been
adjacent to all of these huge historical
events in the star wars
so like it's like you see him like he's
he's like floating around in that
floating bassinet like while the death
star's being built to fully operational
power and then like leaves a day before
it explodes
and you mad child how do you feel
i had to go b yeah that's the voice that
it needs to have
everyone hates the show now um
all right uh we're gonna close out with
another segment of man
does and man don'ts it is our
connections corner where we're gonna own
up to the mistakes we've made
but really aggressively defend our
stances that's right and brag about what
we got right
all right our first doe or do um i think
we did predict last week that mando and
ahsoka would fight briefly and that we
would learn a lot about
baby ota's past and the child's name
yeah and we learned the name that was
great
and his name was not derek as i
predicted so that's the type
that's a man don't for me uh another man
don't
that i have to own up to i did mess up
in the chapter 12 breakdown by saying
that palpatine's son was not a clone uh
the rise of skywalker novelization
revealed that he was actually a strand
cast i didn't know that because
i didn't read the rise of skywalker
novelization like many of you i was
ready to move
on from the rise of skywalker so uh i
have since corrected it and i now know
that he is a straight cast
and i never knew or thought about it
once before all of this so
thank you for all of the negative
criticism
uh another man doe mandu uh back when
ahsoka was announced earlier this year i
did speculate that we might also meet
thrawn
uh and he would appear on the show um
and that looks
increasingly to be the case now i didn't
mention at the time that michael beam
might be playing thrawn even though
that's not at all good casting
uh obviously that was wrong and uh one
final man don't um
we have been calling grogu's blue
cookies macaroons and
yeah they are actually macarons um
according to the
snobbiest one percent of commentaries
among the already most critical fan base
in the nerd world
look uh everyone who told me that from
one
nerd at work to another nerd at work the
moment you find yourself starting to
write that tweet or that comment
just stop for a second and think would i
want to be tweeted this
yeah and even if the answer is yes still
don't we don't want to because we don't
we don't because if you aren't the only
person who tweeted us that
imagine uh 10 more people did and
imagine waking up to find
10 tweets saying that you left an o out
of a word
right and we we like engaging with fans
of the channel and people who support us
but we can't engage with the positive or
thought-provoking or meaningful
conversations
if we have to weed through 15 comments
of like
you actually said that this person was
on this ship when they were on this ship
or that's not the type of star destroyer
that you said it was like
okay fine we messed that up but we can't
actually get into your theories and like
kind of all work
together towards fight you know
uncovering these fun theories or
answering these questions
if we have to spell check ourselves yes
that well put that is perfectly put this
is just about
helping us clear our consciousnesses so
that we can focus on the conversation we
want to have and not being like um
actually on every little detail that's
not what we do here at new rock stars we
look past
even details and movies that don't
totally line up just so we can really
talk about the real discussion
the heart the lines the liver the
infected livers
uh so that is it for this episode of
wikileaks you can uh
follow me at ea bots follow tommy at
tommy beck told tommy
thank you so much this is such a huge
episode i'm so glad we're both here for
it
me too i i what a thrill it is to get to
cover this show every week i
i i love it yeah and i'm looking forward
to next week where
we got three more episodes of this
season there's so much more
to explore savor them all um subscribe
to new rockstars here on youtube
subscribe to wikileaks wherever you get
your podcasts
and if you do uh leave us a nice rating
review on that podcast
um i'm gonna be back tomorrow with uh
the easter egg breakdown of all the
details
um so stay tuned for that because there
were quite a few
and uh we're gonna leave you with our
favorite grogu
moment of the episode
[Music]
you